Oh much money involved in these movies.
If you're going to make a film and he,
you know,
it's some gigantic thing with special
effects and the studio is dumping hundreds
of millions of dollars into it.
They want a return on their money.
I saw people discussing that.
I think Johnny Depp was just kind
of kicked off isn't the right word,
but he's not going to be
in the next pirates movie.
I guess they were discussing under that
like in the comment section like it was
the word last one was the worst one
of the of the lot and they spent $330
million on the budget, but it made 800
million and they're like, that's a fail.
Some people were saying
like that's a failure. Yeah,
for them it's a fairly a hundred
million as it is not good. Well,
Johnny's off the rails right now.
He shaved his head, Johnny Depp,
he looks like he weighs 35 pounds.
He shaved his head,
he's fallen out of his jeans.
Whenever you get like
two tattoos of a woman,
the only been married to for like six
months. These are all bad signs, joke,
and this is a very rough town to live.
Egos and mother fucker. People blowing
smoke up your ass as a motherfucker. Sure.
I mean this guy is spending a half
a million dollars a month on wind.
I don't know exactly.
Don't quote me on that,
but I know that I read that.
Did they say,
they said that he was spending $30,000
and he goes, it was a lot more than that.
He was joking around about it.
It was a lot more than that.
Like are these pictures of him now
stay humble or be humbled? He's wearing
a shirt, dude, you're 55 years old.
Why the fuck would you wear that
shirt? Well, who's walking up?
Meanwhile I got a Derrick Lewis.
My balls was hot shirt on,
but look, these these like
fucking inspirational quotes
you expect to see on some
strippers Instagram page.
You're not supposed to be wearing those
when you're Johnny Depp. Okay, this is,
this is outrageous. Giant Dep. Why
are you wearing that on a shirt?
And I heard that this last movie,
the Mucho Mucho.
What? Pro Banglaz which a lot of
problems. What was the moving the Tupac,
but it's on shelf, right? They're not
putting it out. Is he the shelf? Yeah.
They're not putting it out for right
now. It's not coming out. I see a cop,
the cop, that broker, if you
will. I forget them. That's
a good book. Yeah, though.
Whatever. I forgot. I
have it at the house.
He plays the cop in the area that there
was a loan level and the word got out.
That's it.
Well,
you know Johnny Jab at one point
in time when he had done that,
that movie dead man. Do you remember?
Dead Man? Interesting movie.
It was a weird black and white movie
about a guy who was riding a fucking train
across the west.
He was talking in an interview about it.
He wants to do interesting projects. He
goes, I'll, I'll never be blockbuster boy.
Then he became blockbuster boy, but he's
bad ass and pirates of the cow book.
He's fine. I don't give a fuck whether
they be phenomenal, phenomenal.
He's really good. Good. I love, he's
a great actor. They cut him loose.
He made a ton of money for them.
They did five fucking movies,
but you know he's boys with Stan Hope,
right?
Essentially Johnny d this
fucking motherfuckers with there.
Everybody thinks you're going to spend
money on their website. Guess what?
We're not, we're not paying
to read your fucking website.
We're not Johnny Depp. What
does it say? And biggie, Tupac.
A movie abruptly pulled from release for
Twitter. Granted it looks like. Mm. Yeah,
like a month before it's supposed
to come out. They just pulled it.
Well in my suck. They don't
pull it up. It's awesome.
But the point is, you know, Stan
helps boys with him and he's like,
he said that once he did those pirates
movies, he couldn't go anywhere.
It was over. He can't go to
restaurants. You can't go anywhere.
He just can't go anywhere.
He,
he hit that upper echelon of fame where
it's almost, there's no turning back.
When you know, you get like
Michael Jackson type frame.
You just get crazy. You,
your, your world is just,
it's no one can relate to you.
What were they giving them per movie?
He was making like 30 million a movie.
We're back ended everyday. I bet he was
making more than that than that, right?
Yeah. That's, he's got like 18 houses,
both 14 houses.
You know,
I remember when I was in Colorado, someone
said he had a ranch out there. I go,
has he ever go there? He goes,
no, no. Just has a ranch.